there are a lot of people out there
right now that are talking about things
like neuromarketing neuro economics and
they're based on this idea that now that
we can sort of peek inside of a working
brain that you know we can we can be
much more precise in how we we do things
but unfortunately a lot of that is the
science isn't there yet I mean the using
a functional magnetic resonance imaging
device to you know figure out what's the
best color to make your product you know
I'll strap a guy in an fMRI and I'll run
him through this thing and then hey I'll
have the best you know branding you know
stuff for you is silly and and the
reason why is because you know the
Machine your brain doesn't work that way
the machine is looking at blood flow
which takes you know seconds to occur
the brain is working in hundreds of
seconds so I mean you're seeing stuff
long after whatever the thought is and
then we do a lot of reverse inference to
try to figure it out but and we're kind
of like you know
Galileo having the first telescope I'm
well yeah we're yeah we can see the
rings of Saturn but we still can't see
distant galaxies and we're just
beginning to sort of see this and so my
approach to this has been that there is
a lot we can do with the information we
have now as opposed to the information
we might wish we had and this is a very
different kind of a framework so there
are some companies there's a there's a
knows Altman's doing this with deep
metaphors there's other companies that
are using you know some of the
technologies you know I mean we've done
everything from galvanic skin response
to you know you know EKGs or EEG s and
you know to me I think that what's neat
is that we can actually get this the
exact opposite which is this simplifies
things I know that it really is about
how many times a customer does something
I know that the way habit forms is that
there are a strengthening of neural
neural connections in the brain and
specific parts of the brain I know how
that works I know I know that process
now and so a large part of that and my I
mean I I mean we know how that works and
and what's really neat about that is
that for so many companies now
and just a quick anecdote I helped
sprint and Samsung develop the new
instinct phone so the instinct foam was
built based on this framework so the
whole idea behind this is how do you
make something habit-forming so I
thought about this kind of in two very
basic ways one is habit-forming things
so like there is you know GPS in this
phone but most of the time you know
where you're going so most of the time
you wouldn't be checking the GPS so I'm
trying to get people to use it
habitually versus using you know Google
Maps or using maybe their Garmin or you
know the system in the car I want them
using the phone so there's certain
things that I put in the phone and I had
to put in the phone that were you'd use
all the time so one of things I did was
to put traffic on there so that when you
go to the maps you have a button you hit
and gives you traffic because the idea
is I live in Atlanta so anybody who's in
a you know in a high commute city every
time you get in the car you check
traffic and so the idea was you'll do
that every day that will become a habit
and so everything about the phone was
how are you going you know what would
you do enough times to make it an
automatic thing the other part of it is
to make decisions that are not habit
breaking so you don't do something
that's going to take something from an
unconscious process to a conscious
process so you know one of the things
that that about the phone is you've got
to get an unlimited data plan on it and
the reason why is not just because you
know we want to extract more money it's
the idea that it's the opposite idea
which is we want you to use it without
thinking about it if you have in the
back of your mind you think the meters
running if I do this it's going to cost
me more money how much is that going to
cost me then I can't automate that
because consciously I'm always going to
be worried about it I don't know if
you've ever got one of those shock phone
bills but I certainly have or you know I
didn't budget $300 for a cell phone bill
this month and so you know the idea is
that that as soon as you you you have
that happen then that goes to conscious
awareness and and my big message right
now is that in a down economy as as we
are facing a lot of challenges a lot of
decisions that used to be automatic
aren't anymore
you